As more and more comic books burst to life
on the big screen, the action, storylines,
and casts are only getting bigger and bigger.
As a result, some of the simple mistakes and
errors that would normally be caught in editing
are slipping through more than ever.
And as audience grow more and more excited
to see their favorite heroes on screen, some
massive mistakes have gone completely unnoticed.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Huge Mistakes
in Superhero Movies.
General Zod’s Faulty Clock
Although Man of Steel star Clark Kent spent
his entire life keeping his alien heritage
a secret from the world, General Zod spills
his secret to every corner of the world.
When the Kryptonian first arrives at Earth,
he broadcasts a message in multiple languages
around the globe, telling people in America
and Asia that "they are not alone."
Seeing people huddled around their campfires
or TVs, and learning that an alien lives among
them is a powerful image, but all the scenes
being set at night, no matter which side of
the planet they're on doesn't quite add up.
Since the message of the scene is to unite
all of Earth in fear, fans will likely be
willing to overlook it.
Turned Around Tumbler
Christopher Nolan isn’t afraid of leaving
a few errors in his films since the thrills
or twists they bring with them are usually
worth it in the end.
In the case of his re-imagined Batman, the
director bet that audiences would be too thrilled
to see the new Dark Knight in action – along
with his signature set of wheels – to notice
a few major mistakes.
During Bruce’s first test drive of the camo-patterned
Tumbler, he brings the vehicle to a dramatic
stop with a sudden slide.
But a closer look reveals that Bruce turns
the wheel hard left to stop, while the car
ends up sending the car sliding to the right
before stopping instead.
Making eagle-eyed viewers wonder just how
difficult the vehicle must be to pilot.
Crowded Chase
When Batman finally takes his new Tumbler
into the field, a Gotham City Police pursuit
has him cornered atop a large parking structure.
With cops swarming, Nolan clearly hoped audiences
would be too excited or caught up to notice
the massive group of crew members and camera
men on set, completely exposed by a police
chopper’s searchlight.
And he was probably right.
Wolverine’s Faulty Skull
When Wolverine and Rogue pay a visit to Bobby
a.k.a. Iceman's family in X2: X-Men United,
the mutant's brother calls the police, ambushing
the entire group on the house's front porch.
A jumpy police officer drops Wolverine with
a bullet to the head, taking the situation
from bad to worse.
Fans knew that Wolverine’s healing factor
would bring him back to the fight in no time,
but the actual shot doesn’t make much sense
considering the nearly-invincible hero’s
usual fighting skills.
The first question is how the bullet managed
to lodge itself in his head in the first place:
a skull made of indestructible Adamantium
means the bullet should have glanced off harmlessly,
instead embedding itself in the millimeter
of skin on his forehead.
Why he was knocked unconscious doesn’t make
sense either.
Despite making his claws and bones unbreakable,
is the same metal useless at protecting his
brain?
Of course, there’s always the chance that
the cop was firing Adamantium bullets – but
that seems like a long shot.
Shield Logic
Once Steve Rogers finally starts to prepare
for field work during the first Captain America,
he stumbles upon a prototype of his famous
vibranium shield.
Described as “completely vibration resistant”,
it succeeds in not deflecting bullets, but
stopping them dead in their tracks.
It isn’t just bullets, either.
In The Avengers, its invulnerability is tested,
stopping even Thor’s hammer, directing his
godlike attack into a massive shockwave.
Unfortunately, in the effort to make the Winter
Soldier sequel a more grounded and realistic
adventure, the strengths of Cap’s shield
flew completely out the window.
Not only was Steve able to use his shield
to deflect bullets at his enemies, but kicks
and punches were able to knock him around,
and a single RPG sent him tumbling through
the air.
A Shifting Pentagon
Considering just how much X-Men: Days of Future
Past deals with time travel and re-writing
history, plenty of inaccuracies can be explained
away as slightly different in the alternate
timeline.
– although we’re fairly certain that in
all realities, the Pentagon is technically
located in Arlington, Virginia, not Washington
D.C. as the movie claims.
A Rogue Kitty
Most fans know that the original cut of the
movie had the team of future X-Men seeking
help from Rogue after an unconscious Wolverine
mortally wounded Kitty Pryde.
With Kitty’s health failing, Rogue was brought
in to absorb her power, and take over.
In the end Kitty was simply shown to tough
it out in the finished version, but the filmmakers
didn’t remove the previous storyline completely.
When a wounded Magneto slides to the ground
as the final battle reaches its conclusion,
Kitty is supposed to be maintaining the link
to the past, but can just be spotted slumped
on the floor next to him.
Extremis Measures
Not every Marvel fan was happy to see Tony
Stark separated from his signature armor in
Iron Man 3, but his gift for invention and
careful planning showed he was a threat with
or without his suit.
Even so, the filmmakers may have turned a
blind eye to a few mistaken details.
The brilliant Doctor Maya Hansen threatening
to inject a syringe carrying “1200 cc”
– an amount equal to 1.2 litres – is an
odd mistake for her character to make, but
it wasn’t the movie’s only inaccuracy.
Tennessee Express
Iron Man 3’s questionable math continues
when Tony realizes his suit in Tennessee has
finally been powered online, asking the henchmen
on hand exactly what distance the armor pieces
need to travel to reach him.
The suit bursts in just minutes later: a major
problem once fans start doing the math.
The payoff is worth it, but the idea that
the pieces could travel around 7,000 mph proves
comedy beat out actual physics in this case.
Identity Crisis
For all its action, the first Thor movie served
to prove one point: that godly power was a
gift, not a privilege, and that the Asgardian
hero needed to learn some humility.
He learned his lesson in the end, saving his
father and kingdom from his brother’s betrayal.
Once Loki was beaten, the would-be king chose
to fall into a wormhole in space, eventually
making his way to the villain Thanos, and
back to Earth to fight The Avengers years
later.
But his family mourned him all the same, with
Thor taking a private moment to tell Odin
that he could never be as good a king as his
father.
The sentiment is returned to at the end of
Thor: the Dark World, when Odin asks Thor
if he still believes that the father should
rule, and not the son.
It’s a subtle callback for the die-hard
fans, but there’s one problem: the film
ends by revealing that it isn’t Odin on
the throne, but Loki in disguise.
A slip-up on the writer’s part is likely
to blame, since there’s no way Loki should
know about the pair’s conversation as he
was drifting through space.
Some might argue he was eavesdropping from
across the universe, but we like to think
Loki has better ways to spend his time.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any of your favorite mistakes
or plot holes in superhero movies?
Let us know in our comment section and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one.